so are y'all dating right now
[Music]
it's so fast
because Love is Blind Stars SK alabagda
and Raven Ross have called it quits amid
cheating allegations do we feel like
having gone through this love is blind
or do you feel like no no it's not black
I think Love is Blind yeah Raven
probably singing a different tune now
because on Sunday the two confirmed on
their Instagram stories they broke up in
a joint statement they wrote due to
ongoing legal proceedings surrounding
these allegations we cannot provide
additional details and ask that you
please respect our privacy during this
hard time
the former couple also thanked their
fans this journey has forever shaped our
lives and we are so grateful for
everyone who has been a part of it your
love and support means everything love
is also blindsided so you know
there's that too
the allegations of infidelity started on
Tick Tock in a video that went viral but
has since been deleted a woman claims
she and SK went on a date after the show
wrapped but she found out he was still
with Raven Raven seemingly caught wind
of it and stripped her Instagram page of
almost all of her posts with SK the
Pilates instructor also responded to
fans in the comments who discussed sk's
alleged infidelity
what's your name my name is SK s k yeah
it's just S and K S game Raven connected
in the pods during season three of Love
is Blind every day I feel closer and
closer to you that really meant a lot to
me
[Music]
um it was so sweet so thank you things
seem to be going well for the couple but
SK surprised fans and Raven on their
wedding day when he said this at the
altar I do not
we have a very unique and complex set of
circumstances
I feel like today is not the best time
for us to do this asking someone to
leave their dream to come follow your
dream is a very big ask and I feel like
you know we both had our own reasons for
not wanting to you know for her not
wanting to move and for me saying that
you know come follow my dreams you know
I am not the perfect Nigerian bride and
we've established that so
and I don't know if I can
I came that way just because that's not
who I am but another surprise soon
followed during the reunion special so
are y'all dating right now yeah
[Music]
when we came back to real life we
started living together in Dallas I got
to see really like the progress of our
relationship every single day every day
we were able to communicate more to
combine Our lives our schedules we went
back to work immediately and I fell in
love with him more every day just
feeling like okay I could really live
this life forever with this man SK has
since turned off the comments on his
posts and deleted photos he posted with
Raven E.T has reached out to their reps
for comment
foreign